AND GARY, OTTAWA LOOKING TO KEEP
NOW A CHANCE FOR DARREN
HELM.
HE'S IN, HE UP ABOVE THE
HASH MARK EXCEPT ONE CAPTAIN IS
A PASS THROUGH AND
AND WHAT A GOOD JOB OL.
TOEWS FROM THE POINT TO
MacKINNON.
TOEWS,
WINNING THE DRAW IS THE KEY
THERE.  OFF THE MOORINGS AS SCO
FROM MY VIEW I COULDN'T TELL
WHETHER THE PUCK THAT WAS EVEN
AN ISSUE OR NOT WHETHER IT WAS
JUST A PENALTYHED
THE OTTAWA PLAYER INTO THEN
FACE-OFFS SO THEY'RE NOT A GOOD
FACE-OFF NOWN GETS CAUGHT
STARING AT THE PUCK.
A REAL NG TO GET TO IT THEBENCH
YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE OF WHAT'S
THIS WENT ON FOR A
IT WENT OUT INTO THE ZONE.  HAS
COME OUT, RIGHT?
CAN'T BE A  TO
TOEWS.
TOEWS SHOOTS, SCORES!   A
PINCH OVER THE GET THE PUCK
AND THE OTTAWA SENATORS CAPTAIN
IS GOING TO SEND THE